bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le
livre de politique votre rendez-vous
politique du dimanche soir sur Radio
sensation épisode 233 ce soir mon invité
est le sénateur de Paris Rémi Féraud
[Musique]
ique
Rémy Ferro bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
sénateur de Paris depuis 2017 vous avez
été entre 2008 et 2017 mère du 10ème
arrondissement de Paris vous êtes
aujourd'hui toujours conseillé de Paris
et président du groupe Paris en commun
qui soutient Anne Hidalgo au Conseil de
Paris beaucoup d'actualités entre la vie
nationale et la vie locale parisienne
mais commençons d'abord par la situation
du Parti socialiste votre partie donc
vous en êtes membre depuis votre plus
jeune âge en 1994 vous avez pris votre
votre carte à l'époque où François
Mitterrand était encore président alors
qu'est-ce qui à cette époque vous
attirez dans ce parti ce qui m'a conduit
à adhérer aux parties socialiste c'était
après les élections législatives de 1993
qui avait vu la victoire de la droite
mais aussi une gauche qu'on disait morte
c'était ma volonté de faire quelque
chose pour justement prouver que la
gauche n'était pas morte et qu'il
fallait la reconstruire et que c'était
possible et donc j'étais étudiant et
j'ai poussé la porte du Mouvement des
Jeunes Socialistes à ce moment là sans
savoir que je ferai ensuite une carrière
politique bien sûr à ce moment-là mais
c'était ma volonté de participer à la
reconstruction de la gauche d'ailleurs
les périodes ne sont pas
identiques mais on peut trouver bien sûr
dans cette période de
1993-95 des points communs avec
aujourd'hui c'est ce que j'allais dire
aujourd'hui la situation est
particulièrement complexe au EPS malgré
un ancrage local fort le parti a du mal
à exister encore dans le débat
écartelait entre la macronie d'une part
la nups d'autre part différentes lignes
politiques qui se sont d'ailleurs
affrontées pour élire un nouveau
secrétaire général récemment un second
tour catastrophique a vu les deux
candidats finalistes revendiquaient
chacun leur tour leur victoire il y a eu
des dénonciations de fraude même bref
une bien mauvaise image finalement pour
le Parti socialiste finalement donc
suite à un AR un moment Olivier Faure a
été désigné à nouveau premier secrétaire
du parti et Nicolas Mayer Rossignol et
Johanna Rolland seront premier
secrétaire délégué vous qu'est-ce que
vous avez pensé de cet épisode comment
est-ce que vous l'avez vécu je soutenais
Nicolas Maillard aussiol et le texte
d'orientation qu'il portait pour que
la gauche ne soit pas dans la seule
perspective d'une domination de LFI dans
le cadre de la nupes sans perspective
d'évolution avec un parti socialiste qui
retrouve sa place centrale sa dynamique
et sa capacité d'impulser une nouvelle
gauche et donc comme tous les militants
j'ai vécu avec une certaine inquiétude
la semaine après
l'élection du premier secrétaire et 55
ans même si on pouvait s'attendre à un
résultat proche du 55 ans et donc à des
contestations j'ai regretté que le PS en
soit encore aujourd'hui
à être incapable d'organiser dans
chacune de ces sections un scrutin
transparent mais je me réjouis d'abord
que les militants socialistes par leur
vote qui était une surprise et mis un
coup d'arrêt à cette enfermement dans
une gauche dominée par EFI et vous lui
redressez la tête et que cela oblige
Olivier Faure reconduit comme premier
secrétaire à le prendre en compte à le
prendre en compte dans l'orientation du
parti je le crois demain mais aussi dans
la gouvernance avec
deux premiers secrétaires délégués dont
Nicolas Mayer Rossignol l'arrangement
comme vous dites qui est un accord
politique
cet accord politique conforme au vote
des militants socialistes à l'esprit de
leur vote et c'est ça qui me semble
important il représente l'ensemble du
Parti socialiste qu'elles doivent être
les grands objectifs maintenant du parti
socialisme maintenant que l'équipe la de
l'équipe dirigeante est en place ça doit
être de retrouver ses couleurs et de
retrouver des couleurs de se remettre au
travail de défendre les siens et de
d'imprimer sa marque dans l'union de la
gauche et je crois que c'est ce que nous
faisons ici au Sénat et c'est ce que
fait aussi le groupe socialiste à
l'Assemblée nationale bref nous avons
tout à reconstruire cela demande du
travail et aussi la volonté et la fierté
de notre identité politique ou comme
vous le disiez vous-même dans votre
introduction nous ne sommes ni
macroniste et nous ne le serons jamais
ni mélenchoniste nous voulons une union
de la gauche qui soit en capacité de
porter un projet et une alternative pour
2027 et nous voulons aussi une union de
la gauche qui continue dans les
territoires où nous sommes en
responsabilité ou nous changeons aussi
la vie ou nous menons des politiques
publiques nous voulons continuer de le
faire évidemment et non pas balayer cela
d'un revers de main et pour commencer
donc cette nouvelle page au PS il y a
déjà cette réforme des retraites vous
êtes très mobilisé sur le sujet vous
avez participé avec plusieurs députés de
la nupes à une réunion publique dans le
10e arrondissement où vous étiez ancien
maire vous avez manifesté dans la rue
contre cette réforme aussi également un
sondage Ifop affirme que 69 % des
Français sont contre cette réforme vous
le ressentez vous aussi au quotidien oui
je ne connais d'ailleurs quasiment
personne qui soit pour et 69% des
Français sont contre mais le chiffre est
encore plus élevé chez ceux qui
travaillent et le gouvernement pour le
moment fait la sourde oreille même s'il
est sur la défensive et toute notre
force doit être mise dans cette bataille
contre cette régression sociale c'est
extrêmement important politiquement pour
la gauche mais aussi pour le pays si
cette réforme passe si cette injustice
passe alors je suis très inquiet pour
les conséquences dans le pays ensuite le
débat voilà justement débuter cette
semaine dans l'hémicycle à l'Assemblée
nationale dans une ambiance très tendue
les députés de la nupesse empêchant le
ministre du Travail de de prendre la
parole Olivier du soft depuis le Sénat
comment est-ce que vous avez vu cette
scène qu'est-ce qui est-ce que cette
scène vous a surpris elle ne m'a pas
surpris parce que c'est l'ambiance de
l'Assemblée nationale
je crois que certains dénoncent une
bordélisation est-ce que vous le voyez
comme ça
je pense que parfois il faut faire
attention à l'image qu'on renvoie aux
Français dans la tenue des débats
parlementaires
oui mais c'est un détail parce que pour
l'essentiel j'ai vu aussi des
interventions magnifiques celle de
François Ruffin l'interpellation hier de
notre collègue socialiste
ignyaki et Shanice qui a renvoyé Olivier
dussobe à son imposture en relisant la
même question
dans sa réponse Olivier donc ne
focalisons pas toujours sur l'accessoire
ou sur certains moments de tension du
débat parlementaire qui en effet
existent à l'Assemblée et ne sont pas du
tout les mêmes au Sénat
pensons à l'essentiel et l'essentiel
c'est que aujourd'hui la gauche malgré
ses différences ces divergences c'est
des accords est entièrement uni et
mobilisé dans la défense des Français
contre la réforme des retraites alors
sur cette réforme des retraites si on
sort un peu du spectre français et qu'on
regarde un peu chez nos voisins on voit
qu'au Royaume-Uni c'est 66 ans en
Espagne on part à la retraite à 65 ans
en Allemagne c'est 65 ans et 10 mois et
ça passera progressivement à 67 ans en
2031 en Italie c'est déjà 67 ans alors
quand on voit nos voisins c'est vrai
qu'on peut se demander pourquoi la
France devrait rester une exception en
Europe mais quelle est notre modèle
social quel est notre objectif en termes
de modèles social c'est cela la question
qu'il faut se poser et quand on fait des
comparatifs il faut comparer en
Allemagne
l'emploi des seniors est bien plus
développé qu'en France au Danemark il y
a une allocation Jeunesse au Royaume-Uni
est-ce que c'est vraiment le modèle
social qu'on veut pour notre pays donc
c'est comparaisons européennes sont à la
fois quand elles sont faites toujours
incomplètes et par ailleurs est-ce que
c'est notre ambition est-ce que il y a
une exception culturelle dans ces pays
d'Europe non donc est-ce qu'on doit la
supprimer en France moi je pense que il
faut tout mettre sur la table quand on
fait des comparaisons et donner aussi de
l'espoir aux Français depuis 2017
Emmanuel Macron mène ce qu'il appelle la
politique de l'offre c'est à dire
pour les entreprises et pour les plus
riches qui détiennent le capital et cela
devait ruisseler et bien aujourd'hui
nous avons une réforme de ruissellement
à l'envers c'est assez désespérant pour
les Français et moi je m'inquiète
vraiment de l'état d'esprit du pays si
cette réforme passait outre l'injustice
qu'elle représente après la crise du
covid la crise de l'inflation alors que
la guerre est à nos portes il y avait
une possibilité tout de même que cette
réforme des retraites soit soumise à
référendum comme c'est la motion portée
par le rassemblement national qui a été
retenu par tirage au sort les députés de
la nups PS compris ont décidé de
boycotter donc ce vote alors que votre
famille politique avait voté exactement
avait proposé exactement la même motion
qui allait aboutir au même résultat au
même but les députés EPS ont eu raison
selon vous de faire passer d'abord l'ego
des parties avant les idées politiques
entièrement raison parce qu'ils n'ont
absolument pas fait passer l'ego des
parties avant ils ont fait progresser le
refus absolu et total de toute
complicité avec l'extrême droite en
priorité et ils ont eu absolument raison
de le faire je n'aurais pas compris
qu'il fasse le contraire mais je n'avais
aucun doute sur leur position on ne joue
jamais avec l'extrême droite c'est le
principe prioritaire et nous y serons
fidèles rassemblement national vote donc
des mesures proposées par la nups pas de
souci mais si donc la nups ne sera
jamais des propositions qui viennent du
Front National et quand ils les votent
nous ne réclamons jamais leur vote la
mairie de Paris a également mobilisé
contre cette réforme des retraites la
mairie est en grève les jours de
mobilisation est-ce que c'est le rôle
d'un service public le soutien était
très critiqué notamment par votre
opposition de droite au Conseil de Paris
plus il le critique plus il lui donne de
la visibilité donc c'est parfait parce
que notre mobilisation
nous la menons justement pour qu'elle
soit vue et entendue mais attention à ne
pas conf nouvelles choses la mairie
n'est pas en grève un certain nombre
d'agents publics sont font grève ce qui
est leur droit et en effet ils sont
nombreux la mairie affiche sa solidarité
avec le mouvement social elle ne ferme
pas elle-même ses services et cela
consiste essentiellement à l'afficher
sur les bâtiments publics sur l'hôtel de
ville les mairies d'arrondissement dont
le maire et la majorité de gauche et à
fermer pour les journées de grève les
expositions la boutique de l'hôtel de
ville en aucun cas les services qui sont
absolument nécessaires aux habitants
s'ils sont fermés c'est parce que les
agents publics sont en grève ça n'est
pas une décision de la mairie donc ne
confondons pas tout mais notre
mobilisation je vois que elle fait
parler et elle apporte aussi au
mouvement social c'est bien le but 20
maire de gauche ont publié une lettre
dimanche dernier dans le JDD pour
demander une loi de programmation et de
planification des places d'hébergement
pour lutter contre le phénomène du
sans-abrisme alors que selon la
Fondation Abbé Pierre il y A 330 000
sans abri en France soit l'équivalent de
la ville de Nantes ça a énormément
augmenté ces derniers ces 10 dernières
années un constat d'échec pour les
politiques menées précédemment comment
peut-on résoudre ce problème et quel est
votre expérience sur le sujet vous qui
êtes confronté avec la Ville de Paris
toutes les grandes villes sont
confrontées à cette question du
sans-abrisme et aux nombre de plus en
plus importants de personnes à la rue
parce que la politique d'hébergement
n'est pas à la hauteur des besoins et
parce que la politique du logement dans
notre pays est un échec et c'est
sûrement un des plus graves échecs
d'Emmanuel Macron donc la ville de Paris
avait initié avec un Hidalgo il y a
quelques années ce qu'on appelle la nuit
de la solidarité pour justement recenser
les personnes sans abri d'autres villes
ont repris cette initiative ce qui
montre bien lorsqu'on fait l'ensemble du
cumul des ces chiffres qu'il y a des
milliers et des dizaines de milliers de
personnes sans abri en France et qu'il y
a des familles et des enfants parmi ces
sans-abris et donc cette tribune des
maires d'une vingtaine de villes en
France elle a pour but d'interpeller
l'État pour réclamer une loi de
programmation et le développement des
structures d'hébergement et de logements
nécessaires pour que personne ne soit à
la rue dans notre pays a commencé par le
fait qu'il n'y ait aucune famille et
aucun enfant à la rue si le gouvernement
ne s'empare pas de cette interpellation
pour vraiment travailler avec les
collectivités et développer justement
cette offre d'hébergement nous
déposerons une proposition de loi au
Sénat pour faire avancer
le débat et l'action publique sur ce
sujet qui est absolument essentiel on le
sait dans chacune de nos grandes villes
toujours dans la problématique du
logement une loi anti-squat a récemment
été adoptée par le Sénat la nouvelle loi
triple désormais les sanctions contre
les squatteurs qui risqueront 45000
euros d'amende et trois ans
d'emprisonnement si la loi est adoptée
en dernière lecture à l'Assemblée
nationale les locataires qui ne paieront
pas leur loyer qui seront exclus
exposeront également une forte amende
s'ils ne quitte pas les lieux alors
pourquoi est-ce que vous vous avez voté
contre cette loi anti-squate exactement
pour la raison dont nous parlions dans
votre question précédente il y a
plusieurs centaines de milliers de sans
abri en France et ce que nous propose là
en l'occurrence
la droite c'est de faire une loi
anti-squatte supplémentaire sans parent
de quelques faits divers de quelques cas
qui sont en effet scandaleux et sur
laquelle la justice est saisie pour
généraliser à l'ensemble des personnes
qui ont notamment des difficultés pour
payer leur loyer donc avant de faire une
loi anti-squat il faut d'abord mener une
action qui permette à chacun d'être
d'avoir un toit sur la tête dans notre
pays ensuite on pourra faire une loi
anti-squat mais par rapport à la
situation sociale et de l'exclusion dans
notre pays cette loi est
particulièrement malvenue et même
scandaleuse mais cette loi est en passe
d'être voté en revanche vous avez
remporté la bataille sur l'inscription
de l'avortement dans la Constitution le
Sénat étant en majorité à droite ce
n'était pas gagné d'avance mais ces
sénateurs LR ont finalement décidé de
voter pour votre proposition l'Assemblée
nationale doit encore l'adopter en
deuxième les tuteur pourquoi cette loi
est symboliquement importante selon vous
nous avons remporté une bataille au
Sénat parce que il ne faut pas se
tromper n'avons pas inscrit le droit à
l'IVG dans la Constitution nous avons
gagné une bataille
qui n'était pas gagné d'avance c'était
même une bonne surprise au Sénat parce
qu'un certain nombre de sénateurs de
droite ont bougé pourquoi c'est
essentiel de l'inscrire dans la
Constitution parce que nous avons vu aux
États-Unis ce qui se passe cette volonté
de remettre en cause le droit à
l'avortement dans un certain nombre
d'États c'est toujours une priorité des
extrêmes droites lorsqu'elles arrivent
au pouvoir personne ne peut dire que la
France est à l'abri de cela et
le recul des droits des femmes sont
toujours une des premières conséquences
de l'arrivée de gouvernement de
dirigeants très réactionnaires c'est une
possibilité en France et donc c'est
absolument
c'est vraiment important que nous
puissions aujourd'hui inscrire le droit
à l'avortement dans dans la Constitution
pour protéger les femmes d'évolution
politique qui pourrait être qui peuvent
exister dans notre pays alors que ce
soit bien clair si le droit à
l'avortement est inscrit à la
constitution
on pourra plus revenir dessus comment ça
se passera une loi ne pourrait pas
revenir dessus pour revenir dessus il
faudrait changer la constitution ce qui
est évidemment beaucoup plus difficile
ce qui nécessite un vote des assemblées
du Congrès ce qui nécessitait
éventuellement un référendum et donc les
françaises seraient protégés d'une loi
qui remettrait simplement en cause
l'avortement ça ne pourrait pas se faire
par une simple majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale ça ne pourrait pas se faire
par un 49-3 et donc nous reconnaîtrions
le droit à l'IVG comme un droit
essentiel inscrit dans la Constitution
et je crois que l'IVG est un droit
essentiel qui mérite d'être inscrit dans
la Constitution l'hebdopolitique
[Musique]
toujours avec Rémi Féraud sénateur de
Paris et président du groupe Paris en
commun au Conseil de Paris vous avez
monsieur Ferro je n'en doute pas vu
comme nous cette une du Parisien
dimanche dernier Paris perd ses
habitants moins 123000 habitants en 10
ans est-ce que ce chiffre est inquiétant
non il n'est pas inquiétant et il
correspond à une tendance démographique
qui était annoncée après d'ailleurs une
assez importante augmentation de la
population parisienne dans les années
précédentes dans les années 2000 ce sur
quoi il faut être vigilant c'est que les
Parisiens et bien accès au logement et
que il ne soit pas privé de cet accès au
logement par le développement notamment
des du phénomène Airbnb ou de trop
nombreuses résidences secondaires et
c'est le cas ces dernières années et je
le vois d'ailleurs dans mon
arrondissement le dixième pour faire
face à cette évolution démographique
qu'il ne doit pas se poursuivre dans les
années prochaines il ne faut pas faire
des polémiques il faut se donner les
outils et les outils c'est de créer du
logement social pour permettre aux
familles modestes de vivre à Paris il
faut mettre un frein au développement
d'Airbnb et un vrai frein ce que le
gouvernement ce dont gouvernement ne
nous donne pas les moyens c'est
dernières années et puis il faut aussi
davantage taxer les résidences
secondaires et les logements vacants
pour que Paris soit bien une ville
d'abord pour les Parisiens c'est très
important pour son attractivité
économique pour sa vie commerciale pour
que Paris reste une ville à vivre et non
pas une ville musée donc n'exagérons pas
ces 120 000 habitants moins sur 10 ans
Paris a au cours du 20e siècle perdu
beaucoup d'habitants c'est ça reste la
ville la plus dense d'Europe il faut pas
se tromper mais il ne faut pas que cette
tendance se poursuive sans que nous
ayons les outils pour lutter contre
c'est ce que nous réclamons à la mairie
de Paris lorsque cela dépend de la loi
et c'est ce que nous faisons quand nous
créons du logement social Anne Hidalgo
la maire de Paris a dit chez nos
confrères de France Info mardi matin que
cette des dens situation était
nécessaire pour que les Parisiens
puissent vivre mieux beaucoup de
communes donc du Grand Paris accueille
ce nouveau parisien la région reste
attractive c'est tout mais c'est ça
reste quelque chose d'important quand
même cette attractivité parisienne bien
sûr mais en effet il faut voir
aujourd'hui les choses à l'échelle de la
métropole et il faut aussi que
l'ensemble du territoire français soit
attractif et donc la question par
exemple de l'organisation des transports
de la répartition du logement et des
bureaux en Île-de-France et dans la
métropole du Grand Paris sont évidemment
des enjeux essentiels pour l'avenir et
il va falloir donner une nouvelle
impulsion à la métropole parisienne dans
les prochaines années pour faire face
justement à ces défis qui ne sont pas
seulement à l'intérieur du périphérique
on vous parliez des transports justement
le 2 avril prochain un référendum local
aura lieu à Paris pour trancher sur
l'avenir des trottinettes électriques en
libre-service dans la capitale le
contrat avec les trois opérateurs
arrive à échéance en mars ces trois
opérateurs regrettent que les modalités
précises du scrutin ne soit pas encore
communiqué et estime que le doute
s'installe quant à la transparence du
processus démocratique et la probité du
scrutin est remise en question qu'est-ce
que vous leur répondez là ils sont
vraiment dans le procès d'intention il y
aura un vote des parisiennes et des
Parisiens le 2 avril acide ailleurs sur
les listes électorales et que la mère de
Paris qui a dit qu'elle était pour
mettre fin à cette
haut trottinette en libre-service
qu'elle interroge les Parisiens et la
preuve de volonté justement de s'appuyer
sur l'avis des Parisiens sur un mode de
transport qui pose quand même beaucoup
de problèmes de sécurité des problèmes
de partage de l'espace public des
problèmes écologiques également donc les
opérateurs défendent leur activité
économique mais c'est l'intérêt général
qui doit primer dans la décision alors
personnellement donc j'ai bien compris
que vous militeriez pour l'arrêt de ces
trottinettes électriques en
libre-service quels sont les raisons qui
vous poussent à faire ce choix d'abord
on voit bien que le développement
anarchique est mal vécu par beaucoup de
Parisiens qui se sentent en danger par
ailleurs c'est un mode de déplacement
dangereux et contrairement au vélo ça
n'est pas un mode de déplacement
écologique donc
il faut voir aussi ce qu'en pense les
parisiens mais moi je trouve que les
trottinettes en libre-service
très nombreuses dans l'espace public ne
sont pas une solution aux nouvelles
mobilités de demain vous dites que ce
n'est pas écologique pourtant c'est
électrique qu'est-ce qui vous dérange
dans cette trottinette
leur conscient les batteries le fait
qu'on en retrouve aussi beaucoup dans la
Seine dans les canaux le fait que elle
soit par leur batterie elle-même des
éléments polluants et puis ensuite leur
façon de stationner ou de rouler dans
l'espace public aujourd'hui est
insatisfaisante je suis élu je sais
combien les plaintes contre les
trottinettes sont nombreuses je sais
aussi combien les accidents sont
nombreux donc
travaillons à favoriser le développement
du vélo en sécurité plutôt que d'ajouter
en plus des trottinettes électriques
mais si les Parisiens pensent très
majoritairement majoritairement le
contraire je pense qu'il faudra aussi
les écouter dernier sujet avec vous ce
soir Rémy Ferro à plus long terme ce
sont les Jeux Olympiques qui auront lieu
à Paris donc à l'été 20 c'est beaucoup
de préparation on imagine le projet de
l'Olympique a été adopté d'ailleurs par
le Sénat il prévoit d'installer des
caméras expérimentales de déployer plus
de drones et surtout de connecter leur
flux vidéo à des intelligences
artificielles vous vous êtes abstenu
vous sur ce texte vous avez des
inquiétudes quant à l'utilisation des
données c'est ça nous sommes abstenu
parce que d'abord nous sommes très
favorables à l'organisation des Jeux
Olympiques leur bonne organisation avec
l'ensemble des acteurs mais nous avons
trouvé qu'il n'y avait pas dans la
version du projet de loi au Sénat après
aussi
ces modifications faites par la majorité
sénatoriale de droite nous avons estimé
qu'il n'y avait pas assez de garanties
en termes de liberté publique pendant
les JO mais aussi dans la période qui
suit et qu'il fallait que les garde-fous
soient plus importants donc nous allons
voir maintenant le projet de loi va
passer à l'Assemblée à l'Assemblée
nationale mais nous avons porté des
amendements ou contester un certain
nombre de modifications qui nous
paraissent pas assez
vigilante sur les libertés publiques et
qui nous ont absolument pas nécessaire à
l'organisation des JO des JO avec ou
sans athlètes
ça n'est pas tout à fait le sujet
avec ou sans délégation de la Russie et
Anne Hidalgo a raison de prendre cette
position très claire
la Russie et son président Poutine ont
attaqué l'Ukraine déclenchant une guerre
aux portes de l'Europe nous ne sommes
pas cobelligérant mais nous sommes
concernés d'ailleurs c'est pour cela que
nous soutenons l'Ukraine avec force et
nous avons raison de le faire il serait
incompréhensible qu'une délégation de la
Russie participe à ces JO si la Russie
poursuit sa guerre contre l'Ukraine mais
c'est dans plus d'un an et j'espère que
d'ici là l'Ukraine aura gagné cette
guerre et aura reconquis l'ensemble de
son territoire avec le soutien de la
communauté internationale et de la
France merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
notre invitation dans l'hebdopolitique
je rappelle que vous êtes sénateur de
Paris moi je vous donne rendez-vous la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de l'hebdopolitique très bonne soirée
[Musique]